hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're gonna be
continuing our coverage of the 1972
World Chess Championship between buddy
Spassky and Bobby Fischer Bobby Fischer
does hold a three game lead but the last
three games have been draw well it
seemed like there was a winner
almost every round or every other round
we have had some drawls seems like Bobby
Fischer is almost content having girls
he's had some very strong positions but
doesn't want to put himself ever in a
position where he could start to drop
some games his opponent so playing very
strong but also going for some draws
that he may not have in the beginning of
this tournament so in game 17 we have
buddy Spassky playing the white pieces
Bobby Fischer defending with the black
pieces sebacic you start out with pawn
to e4 pawn to d6 pawn at d4 just
controlling the center pawn to g6 at
Knight to c3 in the knight to f6 this is
the Pierce defense not a common defense
at this had never been played at the
World Championships before and for Bobby
Fischer he had never played it in
competitive chess so not something
you're used to seeing at this level most
players even today are gonna be playing
more the Grunfeld with pawn to d5
similar setup but you can see how
different it is for your pawns to say
back here on the sixth rank compared to
pushing forward and counter attacking in
the center of the board this is truly a
hyper modern defense meaning blacks
trying to control the center with his
minor pieces not pushing forward with
his pawns and then later on he can start
to push in the center he could play pawn
to e5 attack this in turn the board pawn
to c5 black wants to make sure he's not
passive and just lets his opponent
continuously push up the board what
doesn't want to have some counter play
but depending on where his opponent goes
because there's a few places that white
could go from here you have the Austrian
attack more the main line with pawn to
f4 and so in this case black may want to
counter-attack on the Queen side of the
board or could decide to just come to a
5 and counter-attack in the center with
such a strong attack from white you
could also see Knight to f3 this is more
of a quieter opening from white not
trying to to be too aggressive just
normal development bring his light
square Bishop out
castle on the kingside could also just
bring bishop here to c4 and you'll see
this a lot of time just once the pawn
here on d6 comes out black is gonna be
developing along at the dark square so
if the pawn comes down here to e5 or
even down here to c5 this still allows
the slide square bishop to attack this
long diagonal specifically the square
here on f7 which is a huge weakness for
black early on since the King is the
only piece protecting that so this seems
like a logical move also we've seen some
plays in recent days 4th pawn to f3 from
there you many times could see white
castle on the Queen side really have a
strong attack and when your opponent's
playing somewhat passive early on having
a strong attack many times is a good
option we see buddy Spassky playing at
the main line that the Austrian attack
the pawn to f4 and then Bishop to g7
this was always gonna be the next move
for Bobby Fischer getting ready to
castle on at the king side we see Knight
to f3 and then pawn to c5 so did have
some options but at the end of the day
chose to play pawn here to c5 nobody
Spassky can go ahead and take this pawn
if he wants to or if he wanted to get
his light square Bishop involved into
the game could play Bishop to b5 this
does you know set up Bishop to d7 pawn
up here to e5 attacking the knight
Knight comes down here to g4 pawn h3 so
this is one option but buddy Spassky
decided to just go ahead and take that
pawn here saying yeah I'm gonna open up
the door for my queen to get involved
the Queen comes down here to a 5 does
not want the to take the pawn and then
to lose his queen up here and have to
take with his King here on d8 he would
lose the option to Castle so Queen down
here to a5 this does pin down the
Knights here on C 3 to the King it also
attacks this pawn here on c5 we see the
bishop here to d3 and there's no really
depends on how aggressive white wants to
be here you could play Bishop here to d3
as you did could also play Bishop to b5
check and so you know
depending on how black wants to continue
here we're gonna see Bishop to d7 more
than likely stopping this this is mostly
how you want to defend this so if your
opponent does take you could retake with
your knight
this is protecting your night here on f6
as well also another attacker on the
square here on c5 but after the bishop
comes to d7 have those white continue
here and there's a few options that you
would see if you were to play this in
your own game one would be for the Queen
to go ahead and try to come out so Queen
to e2 may be Queen to d3 you know couple
different options here to try to control
this pawn here on e4 since you do have
the night here on f6 attacking it or you
could just go ahead and take with your
bishop here on d7 why it's usually not
looking to give up there LightSquared
Bishop this early since it is such a
strong attacker in this opening
especially knowing that you know black
doesn't have to give up too much as far
as his game plan here cuz he wants to be
playing something like Knight to d7 this
still allows for semi-open file for his
rook to come over to c8 castles on the
King side very good opening for black
but if white does not do this if he's
play something like Queen - e - well
this Queen on a5 is sort of a nuisance
pinning down this nights here on c3 to
the King here but it seems like a
logical move unfortunately after Knight
to e4 things get very complicated for
white we could see the bishop take here
on d7
okay perfect but still in a predicament
here that the Queen takes now the bishop
could come down was on g7 fianchettoed
just waiting to attack and that's
exactly what you do in these
hyper-modern defences after the pawn
takes Queen comes down here check and
then all of a sudden you could see this
Queen is setting up to attack here on a
one and the King here on f2 is just not
in a good spot now if we come back and
say what if the Queen doesn't come here
to e2 what if it comes up here to d3
still the same thing yes it is defending
this knight here a little bit better but
I can still come down here to e4 not
going to be doing too much here if the
Queen takes then the bishops just gonna
fall right here bishop could take and
then
if the night takes then you could have
the Queen take on since the night can't
take here just going to be giving up at
that material so that's not going to be
a great option after the Queen takes
bishop comes down here to c3 pawn takes
and then Queen down here check same
situation as before so this is not a
great option as well black can really
develop how he wants to has a strong
attack why it's not gonna be castling on
the king's head of the board anytime
soon so while it does look like there's
a lot of different options at the end of
day but these Spassky looked at and said
yeah I'm gonna go ahead and play Bishop
here to d3 Queen to c5 gobbling up that
material so both sides equal in material
now Queen to e2 castle on the King side
Bishop here to e3
does have the option now to castle on
either side the board this is attacking
the Queen Queen comes back here to a 5
and then castle on the King side Bishop
down here to g4 so pinning down the
knight to the Queen right here
we're over here to d1 getting into a
semi open file wants to have a strong
attack here the night here on c3 is
defending this square here on a 2 but
does have to keep in mind if the knight
were to ever move then his knight would
be under attack from the bishop and
since that is you know the only way to
counter get that piece back would be to
play pawn to c3 double pawns here also
opens up the door for the pawn on a2 to
fall so a lot of stuff the White has to
worry about black definitely has a
stronger attack at my opinion on this
board state now Bobby Fischer plays
Knight to c6 getting his last piece
developed into the game Bishop here to
c4 and the knight to h5 this is a really
good move from Bobby Fischer if you look
at what he's trying to do here the night
here on c3 is a big weakness as we
talked about the the only pawn or piece
protecting this is the pawn right here
on b2 but then the knight if it were to
fall it's only protecting this pawn here
on a 2 so yes the Bishop here on c4 is
now protecting the pawn but White's
really forced into this weird place
where he really is just defending he's
not really attacking his opponents all
of a sudden Bobby Fischer plays
9 to h5 attacking this pawn here and now
the bishop here on e3 is forced to play
defender role and so most of the
attacking is coming from Bobby Fischer
now we see the bishop come back here to
be three because there's so much
pressure with the Queen and the bishop
here on g7 I think another option could
have been from here to play rook to d5
you know white doesn't have a lot of
other great options here you can't play
something like pawn to h3 trying to
attack the bishop because then the
knight could just come down here to g3
forking the Queen and the rook here so
that's not a good option here with the
bishop and the Queen both attacking this
I think you have to force the Queen away
something like rook here to d5 you know
not easy for for black to deal with this
right away can always bring his recover
- do you want if you wants to double up
here but this forces black's hand where
bishop back here to b3 it's not really
doing much more than it was before it's
still just defending the same square
here on a tube wasn't worried too much
about this pawn here on c2 so Bobby
Fischer says yeah I'm gonna continue
with my game plan I'm going to come down
here take this night here on c3
after the pawn takes then the Queen can
recapture Bobby Fischer is up in
material so things are looking good for
him
pawn to f5 so we're starting to push
forward Knight to f6 pawn to h3 so can
finally start to push and try to get
that Bishop to move does decide to go
ahead and take a material here on f3 so
it takes the Knights Queen recaptures
Knight here to a5 attacking the bishop
and that rook up here to d3 forcing the
Queen to move but now the Queen has an
easy place to come back here to c7 it's
still very involved into the action now
in it just keeps this Bishop here on b3
pinned down defending of this pawn right
here on c2 Bishop comes up to a g6 and
then Knight down here to b3 taking that
Bishop and if you look at and say well
yes can't the bishop just take the rook
here on I think he can but unfortunately
it's not gonna be that great move
after the bishop takes then you're going
to have the night up here to see five
attacking the rook and then okay what
does white do from here if he if he
wants to just come to e7 he's going to
lose his rook and there's still not a
great way for him to escape if we see
something else maybe the vision come
back here to h6 then Knight takes on d3
s we talked about after the pawn takes
at the end of the day why it's not
better for this so we don't see the
bishop take here on f8 instead we see
just a pawn take on b3 now Queen to a c5
say check so not worried about the rook
right now since white is under attack
King over here to h1 and now Queen to e5
and this was the one spot where I think
Bobby Fischer played sub-optimally and
it's almost like he he gave up trying to
go for it after this he had a great
position right here all he really has to
do is play you know just rook to e8 keep
his rook safe that's fine he doesn't
have a strong attack just with his Queen
um or there's so much protection that
white has over here there's no reason to
do anything else besides protect your
rook right here but in the game Bobby
Fischer decides to go and play Queen to
e5 and then the Bishop takes here on f8
rook takes on f8 so white does go up in
at that exchange
rook to e3 rook over here to c8 pawn
takes pawn takes and then Queen up here
to f4 says hey do you want to go ahead
and exchange material right here and
after Bobby Fischer takes then we pretty
much are aware that Bobby Fischer wants
to go for a draw in this position
there's no reason for you to give up a
rook for a bishop unless you have a
strong attack if you say yeah the the
tempo game means more to me I can I have
the pieces I need but when you go ahead
and give up your most powerful piece on
the board here you pretty much have a
game plan where you know you can get a
draw you're up three points in the
tournament so why try anything else and
that's exactly what Bobby Fischer is
looking to do
so Knight to d7 rook down here to F to
Knight to e5 so this is just a
centralized outpost that white can't
really do anything about black can sit
here the rest of the game if he wants to
King here to h2 rook down here to c1 so
trying to get behind enemy lines white
for right now is gonna be just moving
his rooks back and forth trying to
protect this backline Knight here to c6
rook here - see - and so Bobby Fischer
can make sure that white cannot get his
rook past here if he wants to so
depending on where White is Bobby
Fischer can just move this knight back
and forth here but rook to c2 says hey
if you want to go and exchange off your
rooks that would be fun I think in that
position buddy Spassky would go ahead
and win the game rook first a night in
game usually favors of the rook
especially you know with pawns only up
one pawn for Bobby Fischer should be an
easy game for birdie Spassky Bobby
Fischer not looking to that rook to e1
attacking the pawn rook to e2 just kind
of back and forth not trying to give up
his rook here just keep it behind
continue to his attack his opponent both
sides moving there there Brooks back and
forth we do see someone fold to fold
repetition rook here to e1 rook T to
rook
broke up here to e3 pushed a little bit
pawn to a6 but you can see not much is
changing in the position they keep
moving back and forth here white could
if he ever wanted to take with his rook
here on c6 after the pawn captures then
could recapture but then he knows he's
gonna lose material back here so he's
not gonna have the advantage that he'd
be looking for rook here to e1 work over
here to see two pawn here to g5 for no
real way for either side to really come
out of this head and so we do see a
threefold repetition after moved 45 and
so the players at this point had a draw
so you know great game not a defense we
see very often I feel like Bobby Fischer
played it exceptionally well towards the
end of it I think he had the advantage
and he could have played for a win but
he may have looked at and saw some some
variations that were a little trickier
than he
to to go down and so the other day
played for drawl was able to in a few
moves get to a position where it was a
draw state and it was just a matter of
execution make sure he did not slip up
so going into game eighteen with the
white pieces Bobby Fischer holds a three
game lead hopefully you guys enjoy this
video you're enjoying this series and I
will see you in the next video thanks
for watching